عمرها 20 عاما بالتمام والكمال ونهايتها
قد لا تبدو في الافق القريب هذه العقوبات
الامريكيه المفروضه على السودان منذ عام
97 من القرن الماضي وقد مددت اداره ترامب
العمل بتجميدها ثلاثه اشهر اخرى وهي
الفتره نفسها التي قرر الرئيس السوداني
عمر البشير تجميد لجنه عمل التفاوض مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه خلالها ردا
على قرار واشنطن الجديد اذ كانت تطمع
الخرطوم في رفعها نهائيا لماذا تستمر
الادارات الامريكيه المتتاليه اذا في
ابقاء سيف العقوبات مص على رقبه السودان
وما ملابسات فرضها اصلا المزيد في تقرير
مسلمي لكباشي من
الخرطوم عقدان من الزمان منذ اتخذ الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق بيل كلينتون قراره بوضع
السودان تحت طائله عقوبات اقتصاديه شامله
بدعوى دعم الارهاب تراجعت الامال برفعها
بعد قرار الرئيس دونالد ترامب باستمرارها
لثلاثه اشهر اخرى يبقى فيها السودان تحت
مزيد من التقصي
دعت شخصيات ومؤسسات الى الارتباط والتواصل
الامريكي السوداني مثل المبعوثين الخاصين
والقائم بالاعمال الامريكي في الخرطوم الى
رفع العقوبات ساندها فريق الامم المتحده
القطري بالسودان بالشهاده على تقدم البلاد
في المسارات المطلوبه كالسعال الايقاف
الحرب في مناطق النزاع والتعاون مع
الاداره الامريكيه في الحرب على الارهاب
مقابل ذلك دفعت جماعات الضغط المعاديه
للحكومه السودانيه في الاتجاه المعاكس فقد
رفع 53 من اعضاء الكونجرس جمهوريين
وديمقراطي مذكره الى الرئيس الامريكي تحثه
على ابقاء العقوبات القرار الذي اتخذه
الرئيس السوداني عمر البشير بتجميد لجنه
التفاوض مع امريكا حتى الثاني عش من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول المقبل وهو تاريخ
نهايه القرار الامريكي ناتج عن حاله من
الاحباط وربما الغضب التي اشع القرار
الامريكي في الشارع السوداني وفي الاوساط
الحكوميه التي ترى ان القرار لا يتناسب مع
وفائها بالتزاماتها في المسارات الخمسه
المشروطه لاجتياز عقبه العقوبات وربما هو
تعبير عن ان السودان لم يبقي شيئا يمكن ان
يضيفه ليتس مع شروط رفع العقوبات الا ان
بعض المحللين يرون في القرار الامريكي
حرصا امريكيا على استمرار انخراط الطرفين
في حوار يفضي الى نهايات جيده والشواهد
على ايجابيه القرار لا تكمن في المده
المحدده بثلاثه اشهر فقط بل في لغته
المهادنه التي نصت على ان السودان احرز
تقدما كبيرا ومهما في كثير من المجالات
اما المعارضه السودانيه وخاصه المسلحه
منها التي تلعق جراحات انقسامات حاده في
اوساطها فقد رحبت بالقرار وخاصه الشرط
الجديد بضروره تحسين اوضاع حقوق الانسان
والحريات الدينيه وموضوع حقوق الانسان لم
يكن مضمنا في اللائحه السابقه وذلك كان قد
قال عنه القائم باعمال السفاره الامريكيه
في خرطوم انه لم يكن سببا في العقوبات ولن
يكون سببا في ابقائها ويبدو ان الاهداف
الامريكيه المتحركه امتدت له بما يضيف
تعقيدات جديده ربما اطالت امد العقوبات
اضاف القرار الامريكي الى حاله الترقب مده
جديده قد يدفع خلالها اختلال القوى بين
الدولتين الى مزيد من المواجهه او قد تقود
لغه المصالح الى ان تكون الثلاثه الاشهر
اخر متاعب العلاقات ولم ناقشت هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا من مدينه بير بانك بولايه
كاليفورنيا جانت ماك اليجو المسؤوله
السابقه في البيت الابيض لشؤون السودان في
عهد اداره الرئيس بوش الاب من الخرطوم
ضياء الدين بلال رئيس تحرير صحيفه
السوداني وابدا
بضيفتي جانت ماك
ليجو من الواضح ان نبره الحديث الامريكيه
عن السودان هي نبره ايجابيه
بخلاف نبرات الخطاب السابقه قبل قرار
الرئيس السابق اوباما بتجميد العقوبات على
السودان لماذا اتخذ ترامب القرار بتمديد
فتره التجميد ثلاثه اشهر
اخرى علينا ان نفهم اننا حتى اننا لم ن
نرى اكثر من سبعه اشهر على عهد ترامب
الرئيس ترامب حتى الان لم يعين مساعدا
لوزير الخارجيه للشؤون الافريقيه ولا يوجد
شخص لا في البيت الابيض على مستوى شؤون
الامن القومي ليشرف على شؤون افريقيا تم
ترشيح شخص لكن تم سحب الترشيحي ايضا اذا
لا يوجد خبير متخصص بالشؤون الافريقيه على
مستوى الرفيع للتعامل مع ايه قضيه تخص
الافريقيه هذا كارثي بحد ذاته ابان
قمه مجموعه العش ايفانكا ترامب اخذت مكان
من هو ينوب عن الشؤون الافريقيه رغم ان
المليارات
تم التبرع بها الاعراب عن التبرع بها
للاسف نحن لم نحقق شيء في هذا المجال
ونعتقد ان العقوبات لم ترفع ليس ان
السودانيين يستحقون استمرارها لان
السودانيين حققوا ما عليهم عمله لكن السبب
هو غياب خبير او شخص مسؤول في الخارجيه
الذي يوصي برفعها عن السودان معظم
المسارات الخمسه التي حددتها اداره اوباما
كي ترفع هذه العقوبات ويختبر السودان فيها
وهي التعاون في مكافحه الارهاب تحقيق
السلام في مناطق الحرب في السودان وصول
المساعدات لمناطق حرب في السودان التعاون
في استقرار جنوب السودان والتعاون في تفق
جيش الرب الاوغندي الذي ينشط في عده دول
افريقيه كل هذه الشروط يمكن للمخابرات
الامريكيه والاجهزه الموجوده بالفعل ان
تقدم فيها ايضاحات للرئيس ترامب لماذا
يحتاج ترامب تعيين مساعد له لكي يقرر ان
كان السودان يستحق رفع العقوبات نهائيا ام
لا
انها حاله
مؤسفه حقيقه وبكل صراحه اعتقد انه من
المعلوم ان
السودانيين شكلوا عونا كبيرا في مجال
مكافحه الارهاب وبكل صراحه اقول هذه
العقوبات كان ينبغي ان ترفع ليس قبل ايام
او اشهر بل قبل سنوات هذا امر محزن لكن
الرئيس
ينتظر ظهور مساعديه
ومستشاريه للاسف الحكومه السودانيه تقف
على نقيض خطا ليس بسبب خطا منهم لكن فقط
بمشكله توظيف و في الجانب الامريكي وليس
في الجانب السوداني ط اسمحي لي اتوجه ايضا
بسؤال ضيفي لو تسمحيلي اسف للمقاطعه لانه
لمعد لدينا كثير من الوقت اتوجه الضيفي
ايضا في الخرطوم ضياء الدين بلال حتى تكون
الصوره واضحه العقوبات الامريكيه على
السودان مجمده يعني السودان لا يخضع
للعقوبات الان قرار ترامب هو تمديد النظر
او تمديد البت في رفعها نهائيا من اليوم
الاربعاء وهو موعد البت نهائيا في رفع
العقوبات نهائيا الى ثلاثه اشهر اضافيه
لماذا اتسم رد الفعل السوداني بنوع من
الحده بحيث اصدر الرئيس البشير قرارا
بتجميد لجنه التفاوض مع الولايات المتحده
بشان هذه
العقوبات
اعتقد ان القرار هو استجابه طبيعيه لطماطم
التحده الامريكيه في ربع العقوبات عن
السودان ظل السودان يتلقى كثير من الوعود
من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
فترات
متعدده في اتفاقيه السلام كان هنالك وعد
برفع العقوبات في اتفاقيه ابوجا الخاصه
بدارفور كان هنالك وعد بتطبيق الاستفتاء
كان هنالك وعد فبالتالي كانت امريكا
تتعامل مع السودان امريكا تتعامل مع
السودان بطريق
الطاوله المتحركه كلما استجاب السودان الى
المطالب تحركت الطاوله الى الخلف فبالتالي
كان لابد ان يكون هنالك موقف قوي وموقف
لكن اللغه الامريكيه لغه لغه ايجابيه يعني
حتى الخارجيه الامريكيه حينما تحدثت تحدثت
بايجابيه عن عن اداء السودان يعني انا
اقصد ان هنالك لغه ايجابيه في واشنطن هنك
عوامل
التعامل بثقه في كل الوعود الامريكيه اذا
كانت هذه الوعود لثلاث اشهر او اشهر صحيح
طيب سي سيد الدين بلال يعني واضح ان هنالك
لغه ايجابيه في الخطاب الامريكي ا ل لم
نعتدها لغه ترامب في معظم مع معظم دول
العالم لغه حاده لكن في في هذا الشان
الشان السوداني ويبدو ان الامريكيين
يقيمون جدا ما يحصلون عليه من تعاون من
السودان يبدو ان اللغه جيده فلماذا صدر
القرار السوداني بتجميد التفاوض هل هل هل
هنالك رساله معينه يريد البشير ان تصل الى
صانع القرار في
واشنطن صحيح يمكن ان تكون اللغه جيده ولكن
العصا لا تزال مرفوعه فما فماذا تجدي
اللغه الحكومه السودانيه في انتظار افعال
لا في انتظار اقوال فبالتالي كان على
الولايات المتحده ان تتخذ خطوه ايجابيه
ولو قليله حتى تشجع الحكومه السودانيه على
الاستمرار في التعاون عدم وجود استجابه
عدم وجود ا استجابه للمطالب السودانيه
فيما يتعلق برفع العقوبات يدل على عدم حرص
الولايات المتحده حرص الولايات المتحده
على دفع هذا المسار في في في طريق ايجابي
فبالتالي اعتقد ان الموقف السوداني موقف
طبيعي وهو بمثابه رساله احتجاج
ورساله توضح بان الحكومه السودانيه لن
تمنح مزيد من الفرص للولايات المتحده
لتمارس هذهه السياسه سياسه الطاوله
المتحركه واعتقد ان الحكومه السودانيه لم
توقف او تلغي هذه اللجان ولكن قامت
بالتجميد لتتاكد من صدقيه الوعود المقدمه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه طيب هل
تشعر في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا
يسق واريد ايضا ان اعرف راي ضيفتي بسرعه
من واشنطن السيده جانت ماك ليجو هنالك من
يتشكك في النوايا الامريكيه لا سما ان
موقف السودان كان محايدا في الازمه
الخليجيه هنالك من يقول انه الذين توسطوا
في رفع العقوبات عن السودان هم السعوديه
والامارات وربما لا يكونون سعداء جدا حياد
السودان هل تشعرين ان هنالك ايضا نوع من
ارتباط هذه الازمه بالازمه الخليجيه بسرعه
لو
سمحتي انا لست متفاجئا من ان ازمه الخليج
قد اثرت في كل شيء بما في ذلك القضيه التي
نحن بصددها انا اعلم ان الرئيس البشير
والملك محمد ساعد في حل المشكله الس
السعوديه القطريه لكن هناك الكثير من
التوتر في الخليج حاليا وبغض النظر ع ما
سيحدث ازاءه او في القضيه السعوديه
القطريه اعتقد ان السودانيين قد تاثروا
بشكل غير منصف اذا اقول نعم اثر هذه
القضيه شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك جانت ماك اليجو
المسؤوله السابقه في البيت الابيض لشؤون
السودان في عهد اداره الرئيس بوش الاب
شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر ضيفي من الخرطوم ضياء
الدين بلال رئيس تحرير صحيفه السودانيه
وبهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد لهذا
اليوم شكرا لحسن المتابعه والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء